Welcome to The Last Bookstore,
a sprawling shop in Los
Angeles where the written word
is still alive.
At 22,000 square feet,
it's the largest bookstore
in the entire state of California.
You can get almost anything here,
but they're most famous
for their collection
of rare and expensive books,
and we're here today to find out how much
one of those pricey
page-turners will cost you.
Katie Orphan: There are
a lot of factors that go
into a book's rarity,
and there are a few different
ways that it happens.
Obviously, titles that become significant.
So, you've got things like
"The Sound and the Fury"
or "The Grapes of Wrath,"
titles that are older
but people value highly,
still talk about, still read.
If you can find an intact first edition,
first printing with a jacket,
that's worth a lot of money
because that book is
significant to someone.
If a title itself, or
an author themselves,
becomes precious to a reader,
that can increase the value of a book
because that reader is
willing to spend a lot
to have an important artifact.
Sydney Kramer: They carry
anything from contemporary titles
to rare, out-of-print copies.
This first edition of Ernest Hemingway's
"The Sun Also Rises"
costs $1,200.
The cost is partially due
to an errata on page 181,
where the word "stopped"
is spelled with three Ps.
This is all so cool, I'm like,
"Oh, my God, was that, like,
a first edition Jack Kerouac?"
"Is that a first edition
William S. Burroughs?"
Orphan: Yes.
Kramer: Oh, my God.
Orphan: Yes, to both.
Kramer: The most expensive book sold
at The Last Bookstore was a
signed, limited-edition copy
of Jack Kerouac's "Visions of Cody."
It cost $2,300.
Customer: We've been
here a few times before,
but it seems really cool,
it's a really good atmosphere,
especially for sitting down reading
and finding thousands of new books.
Kramer: Here's a book about me.
This is great, and all the people here
are just so appreciative
of having the opportunity
to really kind of look
through all these books.
I mean, even if you go into
a standard bookstore now,
they don't have a selection like this.
So, the question is: Are
rare books a good investment?
Orphan: I think, in the same
way that an investment in art
is a little bit risky, you
don't know what artists
are going to become major artists later on
and whose work will increase
in value and whose work
will just sort of stay at
the same level of value,
I think books are similar.
There are some books that are always going
to have a lot of value
associated with them.
You know, if we're talking,
like, "First Folio" Shakespeare,
first edition Charles Dickens,
first edition Jane Austen,
those, I think, are
going to have a stable,
if not increasing, value.
Kramer: Collecting rare
and expensive books
definitely isn't for
everyone, but that's not all
they're known for here
at The Last Bookstore.
They have an entire section of $1 books,
so you can really get
anything you're looking for
and discover something new.
The staff is extremely helpful,
and everyone here seems
really eager to share
the love of reading with
anyone who walks in the door.